[Music]
i did a couple shows this week and
i was like standing in the green room
and there's all these pictures of like
all these like
you know old like legendary comedians
and i don't know i had like this strange
feeling on stage where i was like
yo this stage is a [ __ ] relic like so
many people have performed on the stage
and it was like blowing my mind that
you know
it could all like
all that could happen in like one
location but i also got this strange
like grim feeling where i was thinking
like
is this [ __ ] even gonna like is this
place even gonna be here in like 20
years or something like will people even
consume
like
things this way like i don't know i had
this weird like existential crisis while
doing the show like on stage kind of
yeah like i'm i'm sitting at people and
like
you know i i was asking people like at
the top of the show i'm like who's first
time at a comedy show like makes noise
visual first time at comedy show and and
it was like half the room i've never
experienced that in my entire life and
maybe it's because
what we do draws younger people in but
even then like
you know that's like a stark contrast i
feel to
you when i was 18 and 19 i would like go
to shows and i'd go to like underground
weird things and i had seen stand-up and
music and all kinds of [ __ ]
at 18 or 19. and the fact that people
were like 21 22 being like yeah i've
never i've never gone to like a live
performance that to me just [ __ ] me up
yeah so it was all going to be in the
metaverse that's i dude like
i think of like i think about that i'm
like is this sort of you know are we i
say it all the time but like it as we
talk about web 3.0 it just makes me
think are we in
this last era of in-person [ __ ] like for
real
yeah but that's not the same as vr
although it kind of is actually it goes
hand in hand with the metaverse yeah
it is i mean then you see that [ __ ]
video of mark
picking his avatar and you're like
that's [ __ ] stupid it's not gonna be
like that yeah but imagine like uh like
imagine a bunch of people logging into
like vr chat and watching a twitch
stream and like you can like softly hear
people's microphones like what if you're
like tap into some room yeah that's
perpetually on yeah and like your mic
volume is automatically like put to like
minus 16. yeah have you downloaded that
app have you tried that app which it's
kind of like a version of clubhouse but
everyone's like like you have your
little like little game piece or
whatever and you can see where you are
in the room and you can walk over to
someone else and then you can hear their
mic and talk with them what's it called
i forget what it's called damn no tile
or something like that no i haven't it's
pretty cool this is the thing that
[ __ ] me up with the show was
this this dude like his son he was with
his son and his son's friend they had
just seen theo vaughn
and then
in the conversation i find out that this
guy like he used to be the gm for the
improv like a couple years ago oh that's
cool and he was like i haven't been
there in a long time
you know i'm with i'm with them and i'm
like can we just pop down there like you
know i want to see my people and at
first these kids were like nah like we
saw theo we're good and then he he's
like come on let's just go let's just go
so i guess they drove by and like they
saw us perform like oh we got so they
got a couple tickets
they watch the show whatever and then he
goes
man i've you know i've i've been in this
business for 20 years man
and you up there you look like you've
been doing this a long time
and like that was a compliment but what
[ __ ] me up more is i was like how many
comedians that guy has seen yeah and it
made me feel like i was coming in at the
end of something oh you know what i mean
like i'm like
oh dope like i just like yes that's dope
but i also feel like i'm at the back of
the line kind of [ __ ] or like
i don't know it just and and coming off
that stage where like all these great
people had performed i'm like am i just
like part of like a lineage of like
scrap you know like there's no great
real comics that can influence culture
anymore so it's just a dude like me up
there it's like yeah yeah you go up
there and do some time no no no it's
cash no
maybe that might be a cynical way of
looking at it but like
i don't know i think i'd be more worried
if if i was trying to like make it as a
stand-up comic and that was my only
thing that's fair you know what i'm
saying
i think as an art form and as a hobby
yeah like it'll never die
yeah very
as far as like careers go yeah like
making it now is as hard like harder
than ever right yeah maybe that's yeah
that's probably what i'm hitting more on
is like that feeling of like
you because actually someone asked me
during the q a they're like
would you ever just do stand-up and the
whole room it was kind of crazy like a
lot a lot of people in the room [ __ ]
answered for me they were like nah okay
and it's it and it's like that's crazy
where culturally everyone's like no
there's no way yeah you have to do 15
different things yeah so yeah that's
probably what i was feeling if anything
it's just that sense of like
oh damn like
it's different you can't just be this
yeah you have to be
the guy who
[ __ ] do you know who does speed runs
on twitch also has a youtube channel
that does that yeah and does this kind
of [ __ ] on tick tock yeah and also like
he kind of has a knack for being in
front of people yeah it's like
like you think about it like six years
ago even when i first got to la everyone
was like oh my god you have to go to the
laugh factor you have to go to the yeah
yeah like that was the thing you're in
la go to the comedy store it's so worth
it now it's like oh wait you're in la go
to boa steakhouse yeah maybe you'll
catch a glimpse of
[ __ ] you know like
bracing
uh yeah taunt you know chester racing
grayson jesterson yeah
you know what i mean grayson chesterson
no wait wait no hate against brazen
chesterson though
[Laughter]
no i don't want any beef you know what
it is
you're in l.a
what are you doing tonight i think i'm
checking out the comedy store dude
that's right down the street from saddle
ranch yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah f popping
yes
before or after [ __ ] the comedy store
just stay there dude you might catch a
glimpse of mgk
mgk might be there with addison dude it
might be crazy yeah might go off yeah
but
the shows were good that's good yeah
that's good yeah but pretty cool that uh
what do you call the [ __ ] thing the
marquee marquee your name was up there
tim dillon yeah sam what's moral
love moral man david spade was up there
yeah
you should have came here picture was up
there yeah
i know i would have came but
guess what i did on wednesday
jonas bros oh you want to go see my
brothers man yeah yeah yeah all right
yeah you're supporting the family
exactly i've seen a guy that looks like
you though
no it was actually
it was actually an incredible show yeah
i'm sure they've been doing it a long
time yeah but they're actually [ __ ]
really talented i mean i know
i just i i never
like kelsey has been into them for like
13 years you know i'm saying like
as a millennial girl yeah like you were
into them when you were younger yeah and
now so i kind of assumed they're like
springsteen basically yeah kind of
no but like i kind of assumed it would
be like a backing track and oh word yeah
no their voices are incredible yeah
they're stage presence i'm serious see
you think
because they're marketed as these like
pop stars yeah like in the vast case
like every other case it's like an
industry plant you know yeah and so
you're kind of
doubtful on if they're actually but the
jonas brothers were incredible yeah
no i mean it and i've never been to the
hollywood bowl before either no i i gave
you i get what you mean where like when
you
listen to these pop artists you're for
sure and just knowing what we know about
music you're coming at it like ah yeah i
bet it sucks live or it's not gonna be
as good because all their shit's
processed yeah so yeah and and i also
don't go to a lot of
like standalone concerts and go to
festivals yeah and the music there
always sucks yeah because it's just not
conducive for a good show
but at something like the hollywood bowl
where you can hear every instrument you
can hear their voices
it's like
and so dope and the sound is dialed in
for that yeah yeah
here's the thing though
guess how long the drive was from our
place
three hours two hours yeah
like
how how packed the 101 gets on that exit
going to hollywood bowl is crazy that's
the biggest problem about l.a is there's
zero infrastructure
like
and nothing was wrong there was no
accident there was no nothing there was
just a normal concert so this this must
happen every single concert yeah people
must miss the [ __ ] show because they
can't get in the parking lot yeah yeah
like we just don't fix it yeah
it's like yeah that's the way la is you
want to grow a dodgers game hour and a
half to get there easily it's it's been
that way since i got my license i
remember the first time i encountered
that [ __ ]
i
remember being like raging pissed and
then i'm like oh yeah that makes sense
it's literally one lane yeah for [ __ ]
thousands of people it's so dumb i know
i mean i don't know what the answer is
but it's like every other city can't fix
it has figured this out and the stadiums
are in the middle like nashville this
[ __ ] is in the middle of the [ __ ]
downtown pro and you can get in and out
easily sorry
the [ __ ] so
uh on the qualifying day of
the
circuit of the americas race
uh
so
uh on the main race day we got shuttled
in with a bus and we were like in and
out of there but on the quality day
we had to drive in and so we had to park
like in the regular parking lot which by
the way
you know rich people go to
all kinds of sporting events but the way
it's so in your [ __ ] face of formula
one is so funny
the parking lot is a big field these
[ __ ] [ __ ] come down in
helicopters
like
right in front of where all the poor
people park and then so at the end where
everyone's like rushing to their car to
try to get out of the parking lot they
walk up to a helicopter and [ __ ]
leave
it was so like
are you like are you kidding me
and so we're in the parking lot we try
to get out and obviously like we're
gridlocked you know because everyone's
trying to exit and everyone's losing
their [ __ ] like
people are getting so angry about being
cut off just to like sit in line
i get out of the car
i'm like standing at the door open i
have my hands on the roof i just started
screaming i'm gonna kill my family if
you don't let us out i'm gonna kill my
wife let us out
people start moving
oh that guy's insane he's gonna kill his
wife
we gotta get out of the way i'm gonna
kill my wife
i'm gonna take a [ __ ]
dude
i'm gonna wipe it all over my car oh we
can't let him do that that's disgusting
i was like i'm gonna make my kids watch
my wife give me head
[Laughter]
so
this dude at the front he like walks
down and he's like oh don't go up this
lane go on the outside the outside's
moving
better
so then we noticed basically that people
had left parking spaces open so we
[ __ ] zigzag through them
to the to the front and then
this crazy lady
uh she doesn't want to let us in
naturally and and whatever we [ __ ]
uh this parking attendant like like nods
at us and he's like
he's like you can cut through here and
we cut through and the lady's [ __ ]
pissed
she gets out like five cars ahead of us
dude she rolls down the window the most
caring [ __ ] ever she points at our car
she goes
and she's driving away because she got
10 cars ahead of us
it was
i saw you yeah yeah i saw you yeah
seriously
and you think you can just roll up in
here well you actually can't so i'm
calling the police just wishing that
moment
i had like a [ __ ] like a fake blood
squib i could just squirt it on my chin
and be like i just killed my wife
oh
anyway
you